un plan de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale présentée aujourd'hui l'objectif
est de s'en prendre aux ultra riches et
aux multinationales qui fraude selon le
ministre délégué au compte public
Gabriel Attal le gouvernement entendons
augmenter de 25% les contrôles fiscaux
sur les plus gros patrimoines d'ici la
fin du quinquennat les 100 plus grandes
capitalisations boursières seront
contrôlées tous les deux ans la
philosophie elle est simple on concentre
les efforts contre les plus gros
fraudeurs et on allège à l'inverse la
pression sur les plus petits puisque 80%
et bien des droits redressés sont le
fait de 10 à 15% seulement des dossiers
donc les gros fraudeurs c'est les très
riches et les grandes entreprises les
petits fraudeurs c'est les particuliers
et les patrons de PME anti a
dissimulation d'avoir à l'étranger quand
il y a bande organisé je considère qu'on
est plus dans la citoyenneté et qu'on
doit être privé pour un temps de tout
accès à réduction d'impôts crédit
d'impôts et à ses droits civiques dont
son droit de vote
fraude évasions fiscale chaque année 80
à 100 milliards d'euros échapperait
office on nous dit le gouvernement qu'il
y a eu 45 milliards de récupérés grâce
au contrôle fiscaux mais on ne sait pas
combien d'argent réellement échappent au
fils que s'évapore chaque année alors
vous avez une fourchette vous allez voir
très très large puisqu'on est entre 30
et 150 milliards donc on a de quoi faire
et pour vous donner une idée de cette
traque de cette fraude la fraude à la
TVA par exemple elle représente 20
milliards par an c'est à peu près le
consensus mais l'État ne récupère que 3
milliards sur cette somme voilà un
casse-tête
bonsoir Babette bonsoir à tous le
gouvernement va lancer une brigade anti
fraude ce soir notre chef prépare du
saumon vous avez pas planqué d'oseille
actualités
les grandes boîtes du CAC 40 se foutent
complètement de l'écologie
d'administration ce sont les salariés
donc vous insultez les salariés les gens
soyez pour personne
je suis désolé moi je constate dans
beaucoup de ces grandes entreprises que
je nomme un exemple non mais si facile
de voir de grands discours comme ça des
chaleurs extrêmes en Asie du Sud-Est les
températures excèdent les 45 degrés aux
Philippines ou encore en Birmanie
d'autres pays comme le Vietnam ou le
Laos sont enregistrés également des
record qui font craindre pour les
populations mais aussi pour les récoltes
de riz notamment les spécialistes voient
cette vague de chaleur comme une
manifestation des changements
climatiques
absolument pas
c'est aussi une autre technique j'ai des
gens dans votre genre c'est l'adversaire
Clem ça va c'est bon c'est les nerfs
j'en peux plus des mecs qui ouvrent pas
leur gueule qui sont dans leur coin qui
pensent qu'à faire de l'oseille non mais
c'est vrai voilà alors moi il y a plein
de gens qui disent ouais il fait de
l'oseille oui mais la vérité franchement
je pourrais rien dire rester dans mon
coin et je gagnerai mieux ma vie et je
perdrai moins d'argent avec des
conneries je vous le dis non mais c'est
vrai mais voilà c'est plus fort que moi
j'aime bien parce qu'il ouvre sa gueule
non mais c'est vrai regardez Bernard
Montiel il a ouvert sa gueule quand il
était sur TF1 il a fini une interview il
a défoncé tout le monde aujourd'hui il
est là voilà il fait des UV il ferme
sa gueule dans ces grandes entreprises
je ne vois pas la vraie c'est de la
coffre volonté pas seulement parce que
ça sert de faire de l'écologie
on rajoute durable à n'importe quoi on
rajoute durable moi je vois on voit le
mot durable c'est devenu le mot le plus
simplement le plus répandu de la planète
aujourd'hui on continue de faire
n'importe quoi mais on rajoute durable
et d'un seul coup de tac on bascule du
côté des de la tendance face à une
sécheresse historique
ce sont des mesures inédites qui
frappent aujourd'hui les
Pyrénées-Orientales une large majorité
du département vient de passer en crise
sécheresse le niveau d’alerte le plus
élevé déjà frappé par des restrictions
d’eau les agriculteurs vont devoir
redoubler d'efforts pour le maraîchage
les arbres fruitiers ou encore la vigne
dans certains secteurs l'irrigation et
réduite de moitié pour les cultures en
goutte à goutte de 80% pour l'irrigation
par canaux après des semaines de
supplication Franck a décidé d’accorder
à sa future femme le spa dont elle rêve
tant ou presque adorez sa belle vue sur
le château le rêve parce que là elle va
vivre un rêve éveillé là
terre qui craquelle qui brûle les
incendies de plus en plus violents plus
précoce idem pour les inondations la
pénurie d'eau de nourriture bientôt le
fait que en fait la planète s'effondre
en direction nos yeux et que l'on reste
impuissant face à cela provoque de
l'écho anxiété chez plus d'un jeune sur
deux en France 58% exactement sont une
étude ude parue dans un landset 75% des
répondants jugent le futur effrayant il
y a des symptômes très sérieux crises de
panique anxiété colère insomnies perte
d'appétit
même je te mets des bougies
[Musique]
parce que c'est très
mais ce que notre miss aime par dessus
tout c'est barboter dans l'eau on se
prélassant au bord de la piscine
[Musique]
ah oui on ne vous a pas dit mais en plus
d'être belle notre miss camping est une
bonne vivante au rire comme uniquement
[Applaudissements]
en réalité si tout le monde avait la
consommation des 50% les plus pauvres ou
plus exactement si les 10% plus riches
les plus riches de la planète réduit
leur propre émission au niveau de celle
de la moitié la plus pauvre de la
planète une grande partie de notre
problème serait résolu la civilisation
est un tournant une guerre a été lancée
contre notre patrie pour la Russie il
n'y a pas de peuple hostile que ce soit
à l'ouest ou à l'Est comme la grande
majorité des habitants de cette planète
nous souhaitons un avenir Pacifique
libre et stable
[Rires]